first person I thought of when Tom Brady
who was reported was finalizing a deal
with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers which will
be made official at 4:00 Eastern Time
today first person I thought of because
he helped with Derrick Brooks and Lynch
and everybody there put the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers on the map as champions and
through that became a first-ballot
hall-of-famer by the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers right there on his on his I
guess is he's Plexiglas shelf on which
his bust rest forever and can't know oil
our good friend Warren Sapp I should
have mooch like FedEx me down one of his
what do you think that's right
prime is coogee is comfortable well you
know what when were you were you with us
on the road when when we went to Dion's
house one time were you with us on
Thursday night no not yet
or maybe it's because you called out oh
yeah I was at the stadium that's right
birthday was sterling on set that's
right we were there Dion's closet is
it's not a closet its immense there's a
two-story it's two stories with a
plexiglass partition between stories
wanted stories too so he could hold up a
suit over the shoes of the shoes over
the suit so they match and remember
Marshall Warren Marshall was muttering
under his breath Marshall Faulk as we're
walking him around there he just mutters
under his breath this is baseball money
is what he said the words Tampa Bay
Buccaneer Tom Brady Warren what do you
think I'm excited I'm excited but you
know I was kind of torn yesterday
because I love the kids amis west you
know in five thousand yard passes don't
grow on trees but to go carefully don't
grow on trees you know
in flux the goat with Mike Evans and
Goodwin and OJ Howard and the weapons we
have and Bruce Arians and Brian left
with a come on I mean my defensive
tackle still gotta have more sacks and
touchdowns but we on the right track
right now right bad
I bet so what do you think it's gonna
look like Warren what do you think it's
gonna be a packed house now they love
optimism of a football team and when you
got Tom Brady in the house come on it
won't be an empty chair and Rama Jane
says it'll be rocket yeah fire the
cannons that's what I said I know but in
terms of the aryans offense what do you
think the risk it no risk it no biscuit
with Tom Brady being the one who's got
that I saw him working out punching a
bag of someone around that's what we
need to do go get Trent William said a
little fighter back side of him
Indiantown coop he blew know he can get
away with anything in front of he sees
that right and so yeah you're right I
mean just did the excitement level the
excitement love about me right now cuz I
gotta protect it make sure he's up right
so he can deliver that ball cuz he got
that right arm and that minor his always
ready to go we just can't let him get
here cuz he got a fax on his bail right
let's not let's not play games I mean
he's not a spring chicken so let's keep
our you know the rooster standing in the
yard Warren Sapp here on the Rich Eisen
show so are you surprised Brady chose
Tampa when it all comes down to it one
let's be honest and you know you know
talking here cuz you know in window
football when one no sports everybody
out there be safe
do you social distance in it's all like
this stuff and let's listen to the 15
day plan let's see what we had out the
15 days let's go with that and speak
over the top of this but you know now we
got sports again
you know it was I was just watching it
go down and I said let me call the
office so either I call the office say
yo what's going on my man like Ford's
not here I'm like fours not there no I
will spring breaking maybe he fish it so
I had to call a couple of old people
within when I got the word you know Tom
was reviewing it I'm like reviewing a
contract like yeah you know like if you
don't take a clutch like normally so has
no no y'all leave those pennies out
there on the other side did you know
this is all you know greenbacks in the
good stuff right you know you know you
don't give the golden all for that easy
you know refuse you know like I'm still
yelling at Orlando for letting Shaq walk
out the door there's no ways to that
right and now we had a chance at talk
brake job ty light weight weight job
like Jason light like the GM at the both
great job he great trick a fool cause I
mean if you gonna let a 5,000 year old
pass a walk out the door and say will
you go Tom Brady all right that's right
I know I know and you know I know 33
picks to a 30 pixel to within six pick
six and all that but I'm a defensive guy
that was enough points on that school
board what a bunch of those football
games that Janice was right last year
yeah I know I mean because the offense
again produced two to a pair of Pro Bowl
wide receivers we haven't yeah both of
them right I mean both of them broke
Mike's old record over 13 I like Jesus
these kids are ready to go
that's enough points you give me 30
points I'm gonna make a stick twice on
son get me Warren Sapp here on the Rich
Eisen show now Godwin is one of those
receivers oh he's very special and no
and no doubt one of the reasons why
Brady would consider
Tampa as he did that's okay no I know I
mean there's no slashes in of weapons in
Tampa funny we just gotta find him but
you know offensive line and a running
back back and do what if he wants to do
cuz you know he loves the screen game
yeah I mean
we gotta bring that out and brews and
wants to play with the play action in
look short go deep but he's got that I
know sir but the reason why I bring up
God went in particular is he's currently
the owner of number 12 how do you think
that conversations gonna go with God one
very easy what number you want me to
wear to told me to borrow to coach
there's he's gonna just willingly come
up I mean the number is not big enough
to ask for anything what you gonna say I
need 12 million for the 12 I don't know
I mean warned you I went to Oakland
right I never had a discussion about my
Nova that's why this is so funny to me
that I bring this out cuz we old school
we're over the storage so ray Buchanan
had came to Oakland and he wanted his
old 34 military forwards in somebody
else's possession oh that's exactly what
it was
what's huggy bears son's name you know
to run eBay fires didn't there were 34
right any tales brain Buchanan 343 and
forefoot it for thousands of dollars
right 4044 he got several thousand
dollars for rape you care about okay so
I mean Brady without any discussion did
you get number 13 and now you become you
chase my thomas with 13 who's a better
13 year old play for you rich there did
but doesn't evans have 13 i mean you
know you know irv like is is mister 88
right what if I'm just saying is
receivers are very very rare
like I'm just saying that if you're
receiving you have a breakout season
where number 12 it doesn't matter who's
walking 88 Club Tizen has blended Tom
Brady's gonna throw you the ball you
have a breakout here 88 you know
$200,000,000 is next now when you went
to Oakland no one was wearing 99 though
right I mean yeah Dolores grant was and
and Mike Lombardi see when I got there I
didn't even think about like Mike you
got my number he's like oh yeah I told
the Lawrence grant they're the NFL had a
new rule that the linebackers couldn't
wear the nineties numbers anymore so he
has go to 59 and I gave him your number
I didn't think that would be an issue
I'm like thanks I don't think there was
a rule like that last few minutes left
here with you Warren Sapp I want to turn
you in back in the paparazzi here what
do you make of the DeAndre Hopkins trade
to Arizona I don't know about him cloudy
not you know having a great relationship
and he's gone and now you just swapped
this man for bubble gum wrapper mm-hmm
cuz you know my you know my rule on
running back they come a dime a dozen
two nickels every time you find somebody
in the trance to run the ball well I
mean you're I don't know if you heard
what I've had to say on ESPN today about
DeAndre telling them about a meeting
that happened with Bill O'Brien who who
came out moments ago to say that is
being blown out of proportion DeAndre
Hopkins just tweeted the same but
there's just you know it was giving some
sort of light on there
I mean I was about to ask you that
question I mean what what what must run
around throwing their ball and now
you're giving this halls and I mad about
it
so I mean that that leads us to our poll
question asked you to Warren Sapp right
there go ahead who's the best what's the
best division in the NFC east west north
south saying right I mean San Francisco
ain't doing anything but reloading it's
time to find a way you know finish off a
10-point lead in the fourth quarter you
just picked off the MVP in the red zone
you gotta find a way to put together
there get three points
now you up 30 now you got action ever
yeah but I don't know you know but I
still go through it I go with us right
now cuz Russell Wilson and San Francisco
and then Arizona just so they just all
over the map right now with that one
also
yeah and then don't find him a
quarterback and go to work so
reloading their free-agency him and me I
got that spinning like they got monopoly
buddy well I mean you know you got to
take a look at you know obviously also
the Rams sitting out there to the last
to the last two NFC champions are
sitting in that division the guy that
won the last one
that gives you an incentive dead we're
not far away last 140 Warren and I know
this is kind of a third rail subject but
you never shy away from it apparently
Tom Brady wants to bring a Antonio Brown
with him all teams that were talking to
Tom according to all reports during this
process were where were we're thinking
that Brady wanted to bring Antonio Brown
with him do you think that that works
for Tampa as well what do you think they
cut the deal with him that was something
that he was putting on the table let's
see cuz I think I think I Tonio Browns
had a little attrition Andy Andy had me
been a little better
neither of I I don't know the last time
I saw a video of him it was you know the
mother of his children with his kids
right there and I just saw I know it's
what I'm saying it's just I I don't know
I don't know if you know one thing about
the all season it'll work his way out
what do you mean you know work his way
out because if he has any idea of coming
back to the lead there's a whole country
that's sitting and watching now you want
to put someone through you know video or
do something that's righteous right now
you know right a lot of people sitting
on a couch looking for some good news
so if you want to do something right
it's time to do something right and they
stop the foolishness Jesus well
hopefully he has it's been a few weeks
since that video and maybe something but
that can't be the last
saying that somebody remember when
somebody asks about you to weave
happening Jesus I know so okay so uh
enjoy your quarantine best you can
manage your stay low - didn't you know
everything is in order and I'm gonna do
what I best I can't I got a beautiful
view it now okay and you're sitting back
and Tom Brady has joined your your your
team Kerry self warrant love you bud
right back at you that's warrants at you
be killer Pro Football Hall of Famer the
one and only Warren Sapp